over to Europe now where economies have
been stumbling over a different set of
problems than those in China yes kova 19
and the resulting supply chain kinks are
part of it but it's the war in Ukraine
energy shortages and inflation that have
been most challenging for Germany in
particular Rising prices are a burden
for households and businesses alike
Germany is in the depths of winter
Energy prices are high and for everyday
Germans that's pushing up the costs of
many other necessities including food
high prices are also burdening
businesses
inflation has been the buzzword for 2022
hitting double digits in the Autumn
while some economists are hoping that
rate will start to shrink in coming
months prices will still rise unless the
rate falls back closer to zero
German consumers are adapting economists
say it's important for economic strategy
to adapt to
we have to
um set up our economies in a different
way in order to sustain in the world
that is now uh that is now real but I'm
I'm pretty sure that we can do this
um so the German population has shown to
be strong in this crisis they've reacted
uh quite intensively safe energy
um supported uh Ukraine and I think we
get through this and I'm pretty
optimistic
um that Europe will grow uh you due to
this crisis
the German Central Bank is forecasting a
decline in average inflation in 2023 to
7.2 percent a Slowdown in price Rises
for consumers and businesses can't come
fast enough
roughly three out of five German firms
are pessimistic about the coming year
that's according to a new survey
released today by the German economic
Institute in Cologne our reporter
Chrissy platson caught up with the
economist Michelle Hooter who directs
The Institute
it was a tough year for business prices
for everything were expensive energy
materials how are German companies
feeling at the end of this difficult
year so what we've seen our surveys
under the headline Germany's in The
Perfect Storm because we realized that
the energy basis will change and of
course onto historical height and the
aftermath of Ukraine war started by
Russian on the other hand we see a lot
of problems in the aftermath of the
pandemic in logistics High Logistics
costs problems in managing the supply
chain and realized that in some parts of
the world also in the United States a
new wave of predictionism is on the
scene on the political scene so for the
germ business model it was really tough
and specifically in the from the energy
side
and how are companies coping with these
hurdles
looking back on the last 10 months since
the Russian war against Ukraine started
it not so bad as we expected during the
year they were able to manage a lot of
things we were able to react more more
flexible more agile as we expected in
advance but we see it's really a bad
mood compared to the very optimistic
view the companies had 12 months ago
because 12 months ago they expected that
in the aftermath of pandemic everything
will be better so it changed
dramatically and it explains a bad mood
now you mentioned the German economic
model Germany relies on a lot of
energy-intensive Industries glass
production chemicals manufacturing do
you see this crisis affecting that
economic model in the long term
yes you can say that this energy crisis
really threats for the business model
because over the years before we had the
idea that we can go on in a gradual way
to assess to come to a different way of
production to carbon neutral production
in in all these sectors but now we see
that the price hike are still dramatic
that there's no time for reaction this
is a background that the politics
uh started to design new programs the
gas price break and the energy price
break will help to make clear that in
the medium term it's still possible here
in Germany to act as an energy
production energy intensive production
but it's the question mark is still on
the scene because in some other
locations of the world look for the
United States inflation reduction act
also makes clear that the relative
prices have changed it's not only the
price hike here it's a reduction of
locational costs you have in United
States so chemical production will look
more up to the United States and this is
just a little bit at stake for the
German business model the economic
Outlook has improved somewhat prices
aren't Rising as fast as they were does
this mean that the worst is behind us
that will be the best assumption we may
have for the next year we see a lot of
improvement in the business climate in
Germany as well as in here in the
Eurozone we realized that the consumers
are more stable in the expenditure
Behavior compared to the cloud business
the consumer climate we saw which was
very negative on the other hand in the
end of the year the producer prices came
down they're not so strong for months to
months and before so my best guess is
that's a price hike just here in the in
the turn from 2021 to 2023 from this
side there will be some improvement for
the surrounding but recession will still
we will still see in the first half of
the year and then more adjustments will
will work out and it will help us to to
manage all these threats we have from
abroad